hello guys I'm Greg Alba and I am John
so John and I are gonna watch the
trailer today for pop star never stop
never stopping the Andy Samberg was
called the Lonely Island movie I'm very
excited for this John introduce to the
Lonely Island many a years ago yeah and
it was quite an experience because these
guys they can rap funny songs that also
are cool rare combination yeah not just
funny
they're also cool there are times when
I'll just be cruising around town and I
really got to hear one of those songs
yeah oops some graphic nudity eh oh man
I'll get down some language throughout
ever since I was born I was dope
Connor currently is 32 people on his
personal favor Oh sir Connor surrounds
himself with people who are agreeable
you take a [ __ ] in the Anne Frank House
what's this thing I've ever had a little
brother
if I'd like a mute brother that was
hella scaly Connor second album dropped
today out of four possible stars Rolling
Stone is given the [ __ ] emoji so mix
let's call it mixed reviews
record labels concerned about taking
sales parties getting into stage
gimmicks down what is it
check this out
feel the real showmanship tomorrow pop
music I'm trying to brand new magic
trick kana don't worry buddy you were up
there for like 10 seconds it's a third
of the way to Mars Connor we've talked
about this thirty Seconds to Mars is the
name of a band it's not a fact ash and I
have been hanging out for about six
months now she's the total package
hahaha I've been in this situation
before I think I got these guys from
wolves now let's get
that's total like Judd Apatow kind of
line there I think oh dude that looks
hilarious yeah that looks [ __ ]
hysterical oh my god Andy Samberg this
is like the perfect time for him to be
doing a film again because he left SNL
then we saw him in some movies but I
think we were ready for him to be like a
movie star yet yeah now with Brooklyn
nine-nine now that being a successful
show he's won a Golden Globe I think
right now is a perfect time to accept
them it's like a movie star and you know
cuz I've loved him since hot rod and SNL
I was like it's terrible that's a nice
but a great way to like you know be like
alright I'm gonna return to movies and
do it with you know something that's
also for my fans you know and is I get
the sense of lonely island production
cuz all three of them are all over this
movie you know absolutely it's also
coming back to the music too cuz it's
been a little while since that third
album dropped I think now's the time for
the Lonely Island to jump onto that
scale it's like now someone will finally
give them kind of the keys to the
kingdom to make the comedy they want to
make on a mass scale so I hope that they
nail it with this ya know they [ __ ]
deserve it and it's great to see where
they're at you know I'm hoping like one
day maybe flight of the conchords can
achieve that in a way I feel like the
jokes about being a pop star and that
like the ones are really going out of it
like really me like the gimmick with
that with the with the light head yes I
yeah I love that cuz you're always
seeing like people wearing crazy new
[ __ ] yeah it looks like they're really
taking on this spectrum of pop music
yeah I'm like really making it a satire
about that so it's almost got that
spinal tap enos and a nice amber is
great at playing like those idiots
you don't realize they're idiots you
know there's a very genuine quality yeah
that he that he can carry that Tim
Meadows I love Tim Meadows perfect it's
funny I'm sure Judd Apatow also helped
cast him and walk hard and then he got
him in this too well yeah and there is
the SNL connect this seems like a nice
Amber's you know returning to like
sketch comedy in a lot of ways but yes I
feel like a sketch film you know like I
see like like what you're saying like
those SNL movies you know like we're
even kind of harkening back to some of
their longer form sketches like they
made some sketches that were like you
know half
are long or something like that so yeah
it does harken back to that more but
what I'm saying is is like this feels
like it a legit film we're gonna get
that looks like that a lot of people put
a lot of work into this and they want to
make sure this is great yeah so I'm
genuinely really excited for this man I
can't wait I can't well be there opening
night
yeahi theatres on Van Nuys Boulevard
keep a lookout well yeah and it's just
it seems like this is the big exciting
they can go do a full-blown comedy cuz
you know we know they're comedies their
own comedies are sort of more quirky and
Indian this is like full-blown listen
guys um hey it's great that you're here
you know what I like to see a return
subscribe today come a reject wink wink
do it John is reasons to Jerry show and
he's also blue mouse calm social media
manager that website is bitching and
reason says Jerry all videos has ever
been on the channel it's got podcast hey
called dank ass stubs and you can follow
us on Facebook Instagram and Twitter
links in description box for y'all and I
think we all gonna have a good time now
we all gonna make some love in the
kitchen of Jamaica Oh what your I yeah
never ditch enough where's the kitchen
of Jamaica France or pick up the camera